I think my boyfriend's cheating
on me with my godsister.
I had just transferred
to a new high school.
It was scary and know anybody there.
I thought that was going to be
my only problem in high school.
For the first time in my life,
I started to experience a release
of your issues with my health.
I had all of these scars and open wounds
on my back that I could never reach.
So here I was in this new high school,
live an immune system that was just
kind of falling apart on itself.
But there was one person there
who looked at me and said, hey,
you are really amazing.
He would make me feel like
there was nothing wrong with me.
He would be with me when I was sick.
You would put lotion on my scars.
First three months of our relationship
I was really, really happy.
But after three months he
started to get possessive.
Everyone I was talking to
made him uncomfortable.
It kept cutting off.
People thinking one day I'll make the
right group of friends and he'll be okay
and then it started getting worse.
It didn't matter if it was my shoulder
or my arm or my hands or my thighs.
He had had to be touching me and I kept
making all these excuses as to why it
was okay.
So I kept going on like that.
After about a year and
a half to two years, um,
my family decided they wanted to send me
to the Philippines and my grandparents
were over there and they want me to stay
with them. And when I finally told him,
he started crying, got really,
really upset and he said,
you're going to be gone for a month.
Why do you have to go now? Why do you,
why do you need to be going to
the Philippines for a month?
I'll be here when you come back,
but please just come back right away.
And I felt guilty because I was actually
really glad that I didn't have phone
service for a lot of it because I
had an excuse. I was like, I don't,
I can't contact you because I'm
with my family. I could just
explore and be free with my family.
We had taken these really cute
pictures in the Philippines.
My profile picture for the last year and
a half of our relationship was a photo
of the two of us and I thought, you
know what? I think you'd like this one.
And I have,
it's been a year since I've changed it,
but then my godsister 30 commenting on it,
she thought it was really cute. And
then my boyfriend started commenting to,
this is the first time my boyfriend
has ever gone in along with a friend of
mine.
This is the friend I needed to have in
my life so that my relationship can be
okay.
The next day.
He told me that the two of them had stayed
up until 7:00 AM webcamming with each
other and just talking.
And I thought it was a little strange,
but it was kind of cute. And then
a couple of days later he told me,
I think we need to wait until you
come home if we're going to talk.
I kept asking him, what's going on? What
happened? Are you okay? And he said, no,
something's going on.
And it's not a good time to talk to you.
I was so upset. Like, why would you
just cut me out? Like personally,
I don't understand why
you're doing this to me.
It hit me that something was
going on between the two of them.
So I got angry and I
messaged him and I told him,
what are you doing?
What's going on between you two?
Cause I don't understand and why can you
talk to her? But you can't talk to me.
My grandparents,
I think my boyfriend's cheating
on me with my godsister,
the same boy that had been to their 50th
anniversary just a couple months ago.
The Guy, I told them I thought I
was gonna marry and I came home,
he met me at my house and um,
I had a box ready with all of his things.
He was smiling the whole time.
He told me, you know, I love you
and
my life will never be the same
because of you. That even at school
my ex would still comment on all the
things about our relationship that didn't
work.
He specifically told me if there's one
thing I don't miss about our relationship.
I was taking care of
you when you were sick.
My health, it's all time low. Well,
it's like my body knew that he wasn't
there to take care of me anymore.
My hair started coming out.
I didn't have any energy
to get up out of my bed.
Everything about me was breaking
and everyone could see it.
I felt so bad because I knew
it was killing my parents,
but they were all I had.
I woke up 3:00 AM one night and I was
trying to get to the bathroom because my
skin was stinking.
I heard my mom to my dad,
she was so upset. She's like,
this is getting so expensive.
We can't afford, zoo is forever. My
Dad was comforting her and telling her,
you know, we'll find a way to
pay for things and we'll be okay.
And it didn't even sound
like he was convinced.
And I realized if there is nobody on
this earth that I am doing any good for
anymore and if the two people I love most,
I am hurting.
I don't want to be here anymore.
Like I had had suicidal thoughts before,
but this time I was sure
it went to the bathroom.
I took the rest of my steroids.
I snuck downstairs and there was about
a quarter bottle of vodka and a fridge
that none of us had touched,
so I drank that with all of my pills
that went back upstairs to
my bed and I went to sleep.
I didn't want them to think it
was their fault when and if I died
the next morning I woke up,
I felt nothing and have a stomach ache.
I didn't have to go to the bathroom.
It was like I had never
taken the pills at all.
That was the worst feeling in the world.
After about a year,
I started getting better. My skin
started to heal up and I wasn't perfect.
I went to this one acupuncturist who said
it was because of my emotional state
that my body wasn't able to produce the
healthy bacteria.
It needed to make everything better.
Now it's five or six years later,
it's still hear his voice in the back
of my head. I wish I could forget,
but I'm here.
Yeah.